so first drill static um
let's let's do a securing my grip
like a bar check okay so you're going to
use the
inside of your forearm to index on the
grip
that's telling you where you're where
your pen is okay
and then in this drill don't move
anything to
try to keep your your head and spine
still okay
then administratively reload
don't holster quickly okay
and a hint the more
you flex just like in your body arc the
more you're flexing things not
involved you're gonna screw up it's it's
more of a
retarding of movement of both movement
and
thought okay so um
try to have that that kind of wind
release
to your agency not
okay so everything is relaxed it's gonna
be much
faster try to relax
okay let's try and the second drill
i'm going to add some movement okay
there's no
tactical scenario happening here just
like in your
tachywas these are like just micro
drills
okay so don't try to fill in the blanks
like i'm trying to get out of the way
regarding just work the mechanics
okay no self-defense scenario no
tactical situation there's no context
here
okay so i'm going to take this stance
i'm going to move it over
that's my goal okay
everything else i'm going to bring from
journal 1 into drill two
the only addition is doing this okay
so we'll work from the same um
securing of my weapon this way indexing
on the inner forearm
and i just move to the top
again the re-whole strain is not part of
your drug
it's administrative i set up the same
drill and i'm going to
go to the other side
i don't want my head moving everything
that does not have to move does not move
and i have the same relaxed wind energy
okay the next micro drill
is i'm going to work on my turret
so i'm going to move in this direction
but aim in that direction i'll take
anywhere two to three steps before i
reacquired my
firing stance so i'm gonna move this way
i go the other way
boom okay everything still applies
start from the same index everything is
relaxed
again administrative reset don't imagine
a tactical context
not moving anything i don't have to move
um in your last presentations
you have to think about how do i get the
weapon in the fight
as soon as possible okay and not
forfeiting accuracy okay so
of course that's going to be
the fastest thing but i'm forfeiting
accuracy when i do that
okay and you don't have that luxury
so what i'm seeing
is your final
point is here
and some of you are going like this
i haven't acquired my sites yet haven't
required
having a part having a part okay
so this may be
point b point a and that may be the
straight line
on my front sight
but it's taking that long before i get
on my in my sight picture and therefore
before i break an accurate shot
so what you want to do is
this gun is going to come to this
natural area
and i'm already acquiring my sight
picture
and generally you'll break that first
shot before you hit
your full ideal presentation
that becomes important in this one if i
move to the side
um you're going to want to do that
because if you're doing the point a to
point b
thing you get this crazy sweep of the
weapon
so you're moving and you have this thing
you see and over here you're flagging
other people
maybe it's your partner or what have you
so you don't want to do that
and if you did the other one you almost
never do that so
this is coming up do you see it it's
it's never going that way and lasering
my partner
or or what have you and it's already in
a side alignment and i
break that shot maybe it's on my second
third shot where i finally get full
presentation
okay but i had a first aim shot way
faster
so um as i go
this way boom it's coming this way
and same thing when i go the other way
boom
it's going to turn a tight corner come
up to that
line of sight start working this like
picture stay
one-handed because you'll start getting
too much torque in your body
stay one-handed as you're moving
laterally and as you go into the stance
boom that's when you bring that other
arm around okay
moving to your right for a right-handed
shooter you don't have that problem
and you're going to have your left hand
just fine but moving to your support
side
as your right-handed shooter stay off
the gun stay off the gun until
you turn your hips back in that
direction all right
this micro drill i'm gonna move on an
arc
okay so here i am at six o'clock
and i'm gonna move up somewhere in the
general area
of three of three o'clock okay
everything still applies don't imagine a
tactical
situation or scenario irrelevant it's my
quick drill
so i don't move it does not have to move
and i keep a relaxed integrity to my
movement
tension whatever the weapon platform
is an enemy of speed and accuracy
so tension is
you losing your martial viability okay
so when i'm training make sure you're
doing some extra relaxation
and what you're going to find is that
for you to relax you actually have to
move
slow it's still tense it's just low
tension okay
i should be able to have my speed just
being very relaxed okay
um some things to note here when you try
to move quickly
from the x you're going to be slower
if you don't lower your center of
gravity first
so as you try to go like this this first
step is very slow
if you paid attention i did it on the
last drill
is i'm gonna drop my my weight
first that's the first thing i'm going
to do so if you watch
the uh the two men um
gu what we what you'll see is that a lot
i'll drop my
weight as opposed to just walking and
just walking you have to drop your
weight
in order to cut directions okay so
the first move is pull my drop my weight
and that is where i start taking off
okay
and just like the last drill there
should be no part of me that is not
already moving
and just like my body art everything is
always moving
but not necessarily on the same path or
at the same rate
okay but what i don't want to do is this
hand is here
like someone shot it with a dart okay
everything is moving
so i know where that hand wants to end
up and how it wants to end up
so it wants to get that master grip okay
so i i'm working it towards that
um so i'm moving boom
and around
i'll do the other one from the other
side again on this
arc i'm going to my support side so
you're going to find it
much more beneficial to keep the master
grip
not in place until the end so i'm moving
and again if i do the other one you're
going to get this weird sweep
so bring that gun up to the fastest side
picture
that you can
okay okay now
let's go back to the first micro drill
something's in my hand though okay this
is just representative of
anything it might be it might be your
flashlight might be your pen might be
your citation book
it doesn't matter okay
what happens under stress is the kind of
sympathetic squeeze of this hand
culturally you're often told don't have
anything in your gunman
but it's actually um the and the notion
there
is that you'll you're gonna draw it
okay so out of all the people that i
have trained i have never seen that
what i have seen is that they don't let
go of this thing
and they end up shooting one-handed
which is doable
but definitely it's going to reduce our
recoil mitigation
and therefore give us a worse ratio in
terms of
speed and accuracy okay so
it's because you have so many reps
already with the
weapon presentation that everybody just
unconsciously opens their hand to
secure the grip that whatever's in their
hand
is dropped but this hand
under stress has that sympathetic
squeeze
it's unconscious and you keep it in your
hand
okay so we have to get some reps in with
dropping the thing
okay and opening our hand and this
happens naturally
if you moved away from the academy
setting where they make you go like this
so that you don't shoot your hand
um because you were supposed to bring
your hand into the already receiving
position of the master grip
okay but you need some reps in it to
make sure it's happening okay
so you don't have to throw it down that
takes more time
you just have to open your hand to do it
so i'm back on drill one
i have that same forearm index and i'm
looking at my
spine and i'm doing the same thing
don't do anything different just relax
open your hand for the master grip
okay let's try all right in the
next drill next micro drill i'm moving
over to the side
okay and again i'm just going
into the movement
i don't want the stick to pull my mind
because
i'll subconsciously or unconsciously
create that sympathetic squeeze i won't
let go of it okay
so if you just bring your hand to the
master grip
the thing is gonna stop okay
oh this one wants to shuffle over
[Music]
okay let's go and the next micro drill
was to turn
the turning the one pay attention to how
i dropped my center this time
okay so just move over
bring the hand up
like you want to go
secure your master grip everything will
be fine
[Music]
this side might be particularly
challenging because
you don't have the master grip to the
last second but if you're priming the
hand
for the master grip it's not a problem
okay let's go okay so we're gonna try to
trigger that sympathetic squeeze all
right so
uh she's just gonna be doing like a push
on me okay and i can do any of the
drills that i want
all right all right let's just have her
stressor be
on the 12-6 vector so if you get off the
line then
she would be free that's when she'll
draw
she shouldn't have the thing in her hand
okay
all right so she goes
i let that happen i dropped the thing
and i
go to draw you can pick any of the flip
maneuvers you want
let it get you let it get you
she's not my suspect you can turn if you
want it doesn't matter we're looking at
securing the master grip and letting go
of this
okay all right this time the person's
doing the
the same kind of pressure let's start
like failure
okay so same kind of pressure okay
wow that's it
and i'm just going to create a
deflection a deflection on her
she goes and now
now she is my pointer okay
so i have the same stressor to test the
sympathetic squeeze
but i also have a form that i have to
find okay
[Music]
okay